un autre cas d'agression sexuelle
éclabousse la haquée Junior cette fois
dans la halajm puis à Drummondville
trois jeunes hommes dont deux mineurs
sont accusés d'avoir commis un viol
collectif sur une jeune fille de 15 ans
2016 dans cette histoire de viol à légué
deux des trois participants étaient
mineurs et en plein découpable devant le
tribunal de la jeunesse le identité est
protégé par les tribunaux le 3e nowaker
Sun 18 ans à l'époque clame son
innocence en attendant son procès le
hockeyeur et le fils de l'ancien joueur
du Canadien de Montréal chaîne Corsen je
pense qu'il est les dirigeants de hockey
juniors en général sont un peu dépassés
par ce phénomène Ottawa on s'impatiente
le problème Wake est culturel pense-t-on
à qu'on n'est pas dans l'anecdote et que
il s'agit là vraiment d'une culture qui
est imprégnée dans le monde du hockey
qui va demander l'implication de tout le
monde qui sont impliqués de près ou de
loin dans l'univers du hockey pour la
jmq l'enjeu dépasse largement le cadre
sportif je pense que nous oui on a un
rôle éducatifs mais je pense que la
société au grand concret un rôle à faire
auprès des jeunes hommes pour pour
sensibiliser pour les sensibiliser
finalement cette à ces enjeux de
violence sexuelle le fédéral réclame
plus de formation certains observateurs
aussi des formations pour les joueurs
évidemment mais aussi pour les
entraîneurs les dirigeants et les
familles pourquoi parce que ces gens-là
vivent ensemble vivre dans une sorte de
bulle sont souvent dans les autobus font
souvent des activités entre eux mais il
faut que ça devienne une priorité
absolue de toutes les organisations il
faut que les entraîneurs se sentent à
l'aise d'aborder ces sujets là un vœu
sur papier qui coûte cher à réaliser la
Liga ferme plus besoin de l'aide des
paliers de gouvernement la LHJMQ salue
la collaboration de Québec mais la Ligue
10 butée aussi lance à Ottawa Léa
Clermont Dion a donné des ateliers sur
le consentement sexuel aux joueurs
junior cet automne elle souhaite que la
sensibilisation devienne la norme ça
prend une volonté politique elle existe
je crois mais
particulièrement au fédéral il y a une
certaine lenteur avant d'agir là je
pense qu'il y a urgence il faut vraiment
prendre acte du problème et réagir le
travail ne fait que commencer ici
Alexandre gascon Radio-Canada à Montréal